so we now know man the weekend you know
I know this unlikely pair of pop stars
are spotted outside a Santa Monica
restaurant
making a very public display of their
affection hugging kissing and full-on
making s can't keep my hands to myself
this is not a drill what you're seeing
is actual real-life but it's making us
ask what the he's name dropped her in
his song party monster kalenna remains
but the only time we've seen the pair
together is back in 2015 on stage at the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
where they both performed
judging by the photo it seems like Abel
thinks highly of Selena at the time
though he was of course dating his model
girlfriend Bella Hadid she's my best
friend so we're not uncomfortable with
each other cut to this year's via
Fashion Show in Paris when the couple
called it quits and Bella insists to Ric
that they're still friendly meaning the
weekend is free to do as he pleases
[Music]
but will this new couple alert cause a
conflict of interest with their famous
exes after all Selena's good friends
with Bella sister Gigi the operating the
same social circle as Taylor Swift no
word yet on any bad blood brewing well
one thing's for certain
Selena seems to have a penchant for
Canadian men yes looks like Selena
really is ready to say bye-bye to
Bieber's and judging by the way she's
staring straight at the camera in this
photo she wants the world to know it
today Bieber's even spotted with a
throwback haircut a similar style to the
one he sported when the stars were
dating but Selena moved on all that's
left now is a couple nicknames I'm
suggesting so weekend